zach is with us in new york city to
start off this hour
hey zach how are you hey dave how are
y'all
better than i deserve what's up so i'm
currently a college student
and i have a real passion for cars
and i've been doing a lot of research
into a business
that involves cars it's an app called
turo
i don't know if you're familiar it's
like this peer-to-peer car rental
service
like airbnb for cars and so i've been
i've been thinking a lot about uh
getting a car
that i can put up on this app and manage
it you know best case i'll be making
money on it or you know even if it
doesn't do so well
um at least i'll come out of college
with a car paid off or a very worse case
if it's just a total flop
i can i can sell it for a little bit of
a loss but if it lets me do something
with cars
um i make money off of it i'm trying to
see what you think about that if that's
you know something risky that's worth
taking and just to see your thoughts on
that
so you're currently in college right now
is that
yes how are you paying for college
so my parents are paying most of it i do
have
a little bit of student loans okay and
will you be taking on more student loans
to complete um
it's five thousand dollars in loans per
year yeah
no uh then right now you're not buying a
car man i want you to cash flow the rest
of your college experience
um i'm like you i love cars too man and
it sounds great the idea sounds great
but it sounds great once you have the
cash to actually cash flow that
experience
i don't want you putting money into a
car and you're you're steady borrowing
money over here to complete your
education
um so i'm going to say no
sounds horrible to you but what i'm i'm
also going to tell you i promise you
down the road
if you listen to dave and i by saying
invest into yourself
cashflow the rest of your college
experience get your savings
up then once you build a solid
foundation then if you want to explore
that in the next two years after you
graduate college
by all means go try it out but the key
thing in there
is pay cash for the car you know that's
going to be the bottom line
so when i was your age when i was your
age i was
as entrepreneurial as you are you've got
a
a real passion for looking around making
money you not only like cars you like
to work a deal yeah and you like to make
the the whole
process of the system intrigues you i
can hear it and it intrigues me i'm with
you i i completely understand that
and uh one of the things i looked at
doing when i was in school and i
didn't end up i wasn't able to do it
because i guess god protected me
was i was going to finance a whole bunch
of uh these machines at the market that
put air in your car
tire and you put a quarter or whatever
in there and it turns on the air
compressor and puts air in your tire and
i was going to borrow like ten thousand
dollars
and put these machines everywhere and of
course that was going to make me rich
um it would have not done that at all it
would have
caused me to take my eye off the ball i
would not have graduated from school
because i would have been screwing
around with freaking
air yeah literally and
so looking back on it when i look back
on it it really looks silly
but when i had the entrepreneurial froth
when i was when i had the fever and my i
was running
a fever uh and i thought this was gonna
be my
my way to wealth i i was all about air
machines
you know and uh i look back on it's
almost humorous now
but uh but but uh you know and that you
know
honestly what you're talking about
doesn't sound that dumb as dumb as my
idea was uh but when you look back on it
it may feel dumb yeah
and as opposed to as opposed to what
anthony's saying use your money on zack
yeah zack is a better deal than a trendy
app
to airbnb your car that you don't even
own yet
absolutely and put money in zach yeah
uh and you'll have plenty of chances to
make mistakes with your entrepreneurial
zeal later
[Laughter]
i've made a living making mistakes i've
made
more mistakes than i have done smart
things many many more
but i've tried to do them in such a way
that they did not cause me to take my
eye off the ball
and they did not cause they were not
fatal errors
when i failed at them and so there's too
many things wrong with this story
you're going to go into debt you're
going to go further into debt for school
which you shouldn't be doing ought to be
working your way around that
you're going to take your eye off the
ball you're going to be worried about
this instead of your studies
you're going to be screwing around with
this stupid app and you know it's just
there's just
it's just it's you know entrepreneurs
zach we all are a little bit add
yeah squirrel you know i mean there's
always something getting our attention
and that's what's happening to you here
and it's easy for us to sit over here on
the outside looking in and see that but
you're in the middle of it and you got
the fever
so uh please don't do it that's the
answer to your question
and and it's a headache possibly waiting
too dave and i really want zach to hear
me one of my friends does that
and he says anthony man i just one of my
cars got into a car accident
and the last thing i want you to be
worried about is school now
this business and then now an accident
yeah and it's in your name
yes you know and i'm not sure what
insurance is
insurance has to go up because it's
peer-to-peer so it's like yeah well
or it doesn't cover it at all you know i
mean there's some
uh companies that won't cover delivering
pizza
yeah you know they won't because that's
commercial activity as far as they're
concerned you wreck your car while
you're delivering pizza they won't cover
you
and so you need to you need to look at
all that and and that's or don't look at
all of it because you're not doing it
right that's a better idea
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money
uh juan asks on facebook where do
student loans
fit into your seven baby steps student
loans
uh as far as i'm paying them all fits in
at baby step number two
all right it doesn't matter where they
are baby step number two paying off all
your debt using the debt
snow ball just line them up if you have
a credit card that's
500 and if you have a card that's 10 000
and your student loans are 20 000
it's gonna be third in line you know and
so it falls into baby step number two
there's a an emotional temptation when
the student loans especially when
they're large
to try to treat them in a later baby
step like they're a mortgage
yeah but that is a mistake huge mistake
you need to get rid of them yeah
if it's a mountain you need to tear that
mountain down and a lot of people right
now
dave are waiting for the government to
see what you know our new president
and congress is going to do since you
don't have to make any payments since
you don't have any interest securing on
it right now i'm just going to let it
sit there
and just wait for the government and i
and i will personally say this is my
personal opinion that is a huge
mistake if you have the money if you
have the resources
attack all of your debt right now
especially if your student loans are
your only debt
take advantage of this time of making
payments without any interest
rocking up on you and if the government
does do something down the road
great if they don't you're still moving
forward
yeah hey listen when you say the words
out loud i'm waiting on the government
to fix my life
by definition you have signed away
your life pretty much you pretty much
have signed up for loserville
the government is going to fix your life
come on
let's say i'll laugh right now are we
ready one two three